who owns the Statue of Liberty New York
or New Jersey it should be
straightforward but the island upon
which the statue stands Liberty Island
has been part of a long fight between
the states over there River border and
the islands between them with rounds in
the 90s the 80s the 30s the 1830s and
possibly more beyond 2000 but to
understand we must first go back to the
1600s New Netherland was minding her own
business when England using bigger Navy
diplomacy made the Dutch colony hers
here the trouble begins for England
split New Netherland in Twain but not
cleanly the mess wasn't entirely
England's fault
she was far away and maps in the 1600s
while they weren't bad they weren't good
either
thus the Charter splitting New
Netherlands reads hmm this indenture
made the four and twentieth day of June
in the sixteenth year of whereas by
letter under patents of the Great Seal
of England baring date on or about the
12th day of okay did give and grant all
that tract of land belonging to the
westward of Long Island and men hit dis
island and bounded on the east part by
the main sea and part by Hudson's River
which said tract of land is deer after
to be called by the name of new Caesarea
or New Jersey you pick huh hoo boy is
this not an easy read paragraph breaks
England you should try though this
charter has uncertainty about the names
of everything wrong latitude and
longitude numbers and incomplete
descriptions of the rivers it's all a
vague mess for example is this part of
the Hudson River or not the Charter
doesn't say and bounded on the east but
where and there's another part about
several other islands but which islands
exactly like say Ellis Island and
Liberty Island England said whatever
your problem now and left the young
colonies to 300 years of squabbling New
Jersey said the Hudson float out to sea
and her border ran down the middle of
the river like it does in every other
colonial charter and thus the islands
Staten Ellis and pretty were hurt but
New York the Empire State disagreed the
Hudson River flows round word then
onward these islands New York and also
the river the whole river and the piers
you've built into the river ball New
York
all belong to us New Jersey didn't agree
but when borders are vague bigger stick
diplomacy rules and with the wealthy and
powerful city of new am start of the
conflict New York gotwood New York
wanted when new Caesarea our New Jersey
asked why don't we split the river New
York asked why don't you make me and
also where are my taxes from those piers
and also this island is a smallpox
quarantine now and also stop hitting
yourself by 1832 New Jersey had enough
and called in the teacher our Supreme
Court New York didn't show up saying the
court had no authority to settle a
disagreement between the states which
sounds crazy now but was kind of an
unsettled question at the time because
America was having power struggles with
unruly states then and New York blowing
off the Supreme Court was and helping
worse if the Supreme Court ruled New
York must share her borders which seemed
likely New York would comply whoops no
New York was going to tell the court to
get bent America trying to grow up to be
a powerful federal government did not
want this so the Supreme Court decided
to not take the case right now maybe
later and then America used some
political leverage to get New York to
agree to settle the matter privately
with New Jersey look this is your
decision no need to get that Supreme
Court involved in all of this and no
need for me to enforce their ruling
isn't that better for everyone so the
two states haggled New Jersey gave up
her claims to Staten Island and in
return
New York agreed New Jersey's northern
border extended into the river and down
the middle passed Ellis Island past
Liberty Island squeezing around Staten
Island before going back out to sea haha
so the Statue of Liberty is in New
Jersey no New Jersey also gave up Ellis
Island and Liberty Island too which
seems like giving up a lot but look
river access in the age of steamboats
was a big deal and sacrificing a couple
islands to get her peers back was worth
it and America was happy because a power
struggle between her and the states was
averted and everything was going to be
smooth sailing Oh anyway both islands
are New York enclaves inside New
Jersey's border which does make
answering the question where is the
Statue of Liberty with in New Jersey
technically correct in the most
pointless kind of way now in the midst
of all this America noticed Liberty
Island
rather strategic position and she took
it for herself as a federal land and
built a pretty star fortress upon it
that could shoot in every direction
look familiar later when France sent
America the Statue of Liberty as a
symbol of their eternal friendship a
bond forged side-by-side in the heat of
the young rebels battle for freedom from
the Empire a bond America would surely
hashtag never forget America said I will
put it right here where it'll be the
first thing everyone coming to the
United States will see BFFs France BFFs
forever so the statue was put atop an
old federal fort on federal land and POW
made a National Monument so America owns
the statue
this opens a book titled what is federal
land like what does it mean for real
though which will be firmly closed as a
story for another time
otherwise we will never finish this it's
still only the 60s and we have yet to
talk about the squabble over the land
below the water yes really so back to
Ellis Island for a moment which 150
years after borders were supposedly
settled New Jersey claimed as hers again
partly see in the 1800s the island was
yea big but by the 1990s it was yay big
and because the rivalries of youth never
really end New Jersey again brought in
the Supreme Court this time New York
showed up promptly the added land New
Jersey said was hers New York disagreed
saying the in bigand island was still
her Island now how did Ellis Island it
get bigger well New York claimed while
digging up the subways she dumped the
dirt here in New Jersey's half of the
river but her dirt her new land which is
an interesting territorial acquisition
strategy but neither New York nor New
Jersey could find any paperwork for the
court to prove where the land came from
so how Ellis Island grew three sizes is
just lost to history
but whatever the court ruled everything
above the water was New York and
everything below the water was New
Jersey but if below became above new New
Jersey it would be and thus this island
belongs to New Jersey with just this
little original part being New York
which is a sublime and ridiculous border
that opens the door to one squabble
remaining Liberty Island was originally
yeah but
it's yay which means this part should be
New Jersey not New York though it hasn't
been fought over yet possibly because
neither state has noticed and while it
would still leave Lady Liberty on the
New York side you know what would be on
the New Jersey side the gift shop and
the only thing more important than who
owns the monument is who owns the gift
shop for the monument we will see but as
it is within the waters of New Jersey
there's an island of New York that's
federal land atop which the National
Monument of the Statue of Liberty stands
[Music]
oh there's also shooter's island the
state border runs right through it I'm
not sure anyone noticed it's a bird
sanctuary run by New York so whatever